how are you doing oh how are you
you're like wait a minute i actually
know this person i actually know you
um let me start by saying congrats on
the movie and that i want to give a big
thank you to netflix for making this
because it's about [ __ ] time
oh wow
thank you
it's just the you know every western
i've ever seen is just the story of a
bunch of white people and
and i just think it's about time that
other stories are told and that's why i
say thank you to netflix for making this
movie yeah um so i'm definitely curious
about your history with westerns and if
you like do you have were you interested
in westerns prior to being offered this
you know honestly no i you know it
wasn't really a part of my like
childhood film watching canon i was like
a musical girl so put on sound and music
i was good um
but
you know i felt like
as someone working in this industry
actually like it's really important for
me to
know this like really important part of
our sort of like
hollywood kind of
genre um and so this was a really nice
opportunity for me to actually dive in
and
me and one of the other actors eddie
gethegi who plays bill pickett we
actually we started meeting up every
sunday or like on the weekends to watch
a western film and we kind of just like
went through many different kinds good
ones bad ones just to kind of get the
feel and you know the energy and to see
what we were playing with what you know
what was the sandbox we were working
with um and that was really cool like i
really loved
honestly discovering things that people
have loved for decades and being like oh
yeah like i get it i love that too and
um you know
specific films
and
understanding why this has become such
an iconic genre
and then seeing like oh you know this is
where particularly after doing sort of
research into
what life was like during this time and
also
the actual demographic of the time in
terms of like how you know diverse it
actually was uh it was cool to be like
oh you know we can
uh make
adjustments to to this um you know
old version of uh of the
genre and to sort of make it modern and
make it relevant to um
what we're talking about today and
and also in terms of representation so
um yeah i feel like now i'm you know i
i have a really nice appreciation for um
i don't know these films and and like
does that make sense
no 100
every western always has a big third act
shootout that's like the staple of the
genre yeah so so what was it actually
like being part of a big shootout you
know what i mean of a western
yeah i mean it's very technical um
we so um the big shootout moment there's
some like kind of like
choreography that jonathan majors who
plays nat love
and i do that we worked on for
months and then obviously on the day of
like once you're on location obviously
everything changes then um but you know
that was
for all of us because there are all
these sort of moving parts in that scene
and um you know we all worked really
hard on kind of like landing essentially
our dance moves um where they needed to
go so everything worked in tandem with
one another and you know that was like a
really i think we were all very nervous
to shoot that because it was such a
build up and is an important scene in
film
um
but yeah you know i think overall i just
feel sort of like
wow i was in a western which is such a
i don't know like i can say that i've
done that and
um um
and i really kind of like to sort of i
don't know be able to be a part of like
every genre
um and do like at least one movie in
that and take it off and then you know
do something else but what's fun i think
about westerns is like they're very
connected to nature you know obviously
in terms of you know horseback riding
and stuff like that but just the
landscape and when you're where you're
at and it really informs the story and
um i really enjoyed that part of
shooting really feeling like
you know nat is this traveler and and
mary
has been a traveler with him and
um
you know
those elements feel really grounded to
me and i i liked exploring that in this
um type of film
what is it like uh when your director is
singing and dancing sometimes between uh
takes you know in rehearsal and whatever
because he has a from what i understand
a very unique energy
yeah a very unique energy and a very
bright energy um you know we were also
shooting during
we were shooting in the middle of well
fall into winter
during
coven so it was the latter
part of 2020
um and you know
everybody was kind of going through it a
little bit
and james is just like very like
uplifting high kind of like positive
energy person and he does that just in
his expression and how he speaks but
also
um he is always like he's such a musical
person he's always sort of viewing life
through the lens of music and so to have
that in between takes of him dancing and
inviting other people into that energy
and like keeping the morale up always
like he was i think our beacon of light
of like
of getting us through this with like
positivity and motivation you know
beyond also just us wanting to be there
but it was just it was a lot going on
and
um
i feel like he was this very like
this pillar we could really rely on
um
and then also you know i've never had a
director do that before and that's fun
and it's joyful and when you're at one
in the morning and you're tired you know
and he's like playing something
joyful and we all are like
partaking in that energy it's really
great and also most people also don't
play like music he's a guitarist and so
most people don't
play music when we're rehearsing to sort
of set tone and he was like gently
plucking away while we were doing our
scenes and it was
really like a
great mood again he's like all about
mood and
and he he can manipulate it well
so yeah as
you know um i am kind of a fan of
atlanta just like the entire planet uh i
know i know you've been filming i don't
even know if you've wrapped i don't know
where you're where you're at what can
you tease people about season three
slash season four and
um you know what the shoot was like
of course obviously i can't say too much
we are shooting right now we're shooting
season four right now i'm in atlanta um
and season three we shot in europe um so
that's
all i can really say about season three
before we're shooting atlanta
uh but i'd say season three is a really
really fun
i think
great like punchy welcome back and um
i'm really excited for people to see it
i was really excited shooting it and had
a lot of fun
making these two seasons and what's good
is like most of it is in the can we're
done so it's going to be aired at some
point
um it's no longer like this nebulous
cloud
so yeah i'm really i
honestly cannot wait seriously congrats
on this movie um i wish you nothing but
the best have a great day thank you
until the next time
you